we need goons here for this kid heaven
not watch over us everywhere now I can't
stop looking at him he's like just the
creepy little penguin sneaking up behind
ya an actual Gunther okay what like an
actual penguin what
yeah totally have a gun to running it's
just that you know there's some like
that's so special I like in some Asian
neighborhood like the got a thing with a
lately go run chores they sound like co2
cartridge okay really getting I'll check
Wizards wit wit what's a call which is
garden okay this is the witch's garden
um took us a while but we got there and
okay so why haven't sinned this fun date
it starts off with a frog with a crown
and they just want see if he's ever
gonna put it on they just follow the
Frog pretty much I thought the possibly
funnier Lions just like I just wanna
know why a frog as a crowd a little
funnier but waited it's the employer I
was pretty funny too I guess it's more
random so it makes more sense and they
go into this guard and where there's
donut bushes and one bagel and and Jake
accident not accident well his
subconscious
it's the donut and then his subconscious
becomes a character in this who dies his
subconscious dies which I be it's like
somewhere is like a really deep
interesting metaphor in there but or
maybe it's just stupid I don't know but
so so Jake eats this doughnut and the
which takes away he takes away his
powers and gives him a human body not
just a human like a really overweight
human body um and they try to figure out
how to give powers back and it turns out
he got it from rolling in a mud puddle
or at least that's all he can remember
and so they try to find one but then
they come across a river of garbage
where Casa sent stranger estranged and
the more I say we're a mermaid of the
garbage river comes out puts Finn in a
nest of little bird wings which is weird
the birds don't actually look like
the mermaid it's but they're hungry yes
but they are hungry we know that so they
this is so Jake owes apologizes but the
which makes them do stuff with his
subconscious which that sounds really
bad it can be another interesting
metaphor the more I think about it but
okay so if the subconscious dies and
Jake gets his powers back and then like
throws away the witch's cane like eats
another donut and says haha and that
stays Finn that's pretty much it kind of
a mean episode the first thing I can
think of in this one I really love the
the designs of the of the witch and the
mermaid well first of all it looks
nothing like a mermaid so that's of
course pretty funny um but I know I love
the way the which is totally like not
just hunched over like her whole body
it's just like a giant upside-down u and
always has just one I showing its I'm
wondering if there's even another eye
under the hair that had should be find
favor show that and and then the mermaid
thing which I love the way it's like
she's got a lot hair and the skeleton
body that's weird enough but I love the
way the hair is also the arms hands I
think in like more hair serves as wings
and stuff like I love that's so bizarre
but so creative so I really love that um
so the one other part that did make me
like just it's like two or three jokes
on top of each other it's the one you
you guys I'm coating it earlier the
bagel why you're a good doughnut wait
you're up bagel liar and like transforms
that to have a human body with the
underwear and it's it's funny enough
that there's a bagel in there and then
it's really funny that she gets angry at
the bagel shouting at it like it's alive
but then gives it a human body and the
human body is actually moving like she
probably just gave birth to this you
know terrible concoction like something
has never existed she gave birth to it's
when is something that does come up
because think about Wizard the rock
comes to life yeah that I was able yes
comes to life
so all these like things
usually aren't alive or somehow coming
alive and then kind of being forgotten
about I would love to see that bagel
just like in the background somewhere
like all the weird creatures looking or
having flies and there's just this big I
don't know we're running around just
looking for an identity or something
like that should be the new snail like
in every episode if it's ever shown up I
have yet to see it I so I don't know you
may if they do they're still doing
episodes oh yeah if you're watching just
bring that thing back it just looks like
this really cruel joke like God just
wanted to be like really cruel and make
like the saddest thing in so it's just
it like it has no mouth no yeah it has
no way breathing I just look in I feel
like that is so sad just this thing
existing meredith senses the head like
the Harry Potter parody and like he's
trying to turn a frog into a prince but
it's like this half concocted they it
just keeps growing up saying please kill
me every moment I live is pain it just
reminds me of that I'm sorry I'm really
focusing on that but it was just so
strange and those are the thoughts that
came in my head and made really funny to
me so okay and there's clearly not
really a lesson to learn in this way at
least not that I could see and it seemed
more like the idea was just to make fun
of the fact that it looks like there's
gonna be a lesson but really it's just
like no we're just jerks yeah like
that's the one thing that this episode
kind of like solidifies or really start
showing Jake has a very like a jerk side
that he sometimes lets out this is the
first one where you really see him kind
of being a straight-up jerk he learns
his lesson without question but he kind
of forgets his lesson half a second
later I guess the one thing that makes
it a touch justified is that he
apologizes to the Witch and she said but
you took too long I want you to you know
humiliate yourself kind of humiliating
yourself with him - oh let me record
this so it's like she's really pushing
it so it's like she kind of has it
calling Oh No so I guess that kind of
evens it out of touch but yeah I'm
trying to think I love the house
finished swimming first he's like
flopping on top of the river
garbage then when he goes swimming you
know you see him actually holding his
breath and it's like there's no water
there ya know there's no water it's just
a literally a river of nothing but
garbage and I'm like that's kind of
great that he's actually holding his
breath while swimming in garbage and the
fact that he's swimming in garbage yeah
I like sort of because it sort of takes
you a second to realize he's not
actually swimming he there's just so
much of the garbage and obviously it's
holding his breath cause you know it's
gonna smell him too so it's it took me a
second I saw that Tullio this is
actually kind of surreal like he's kind
of sweating he's kind of not in a sense
so yeah trying to think
does that frog ever come back nope I've
yet to see the Frog all the characters I
would swear would come back like it
sorry like I would think that frog would
come back I you know and you know that's
actually an interesting question do we
ever get to see the Frog put on the
crown I just don't know why as a crown
like what was the you assume it's a Frog
Prince but you don't know oh and just
he's just walking for a long time with
that you really like to think very hard
about small creatures but I just get a
feeling that so much this stuff's gonna
come back anyway so I'm trying to guess
what it is but it's like I can't guess
what it is it's the stuff you think
would come back never does come back no
does the water Mountain family ever come
back yeah okay okay so that's that's one
that I can't get so Stanley the
watermelon just tell me yes it's it's
still not as fascinating as the bagel
though I still want to see what happens
to the bagel again you have this via
this thing for small creatures just from
tree trunks is small you don't buy
bagels do a character no no the bagel
clearly has no character it's just like
a sin against nature I just want to see
how it survives how does it eat how does
it just fascinates me just that its
existence fascinates me so I know
there's no character miss you're the
best and it's me yes it both discuss and
fascinates and I wouldn't mind seeing
more of it so yeah that's about all gone
this one you got anything else
so we when you're weird bagel fetish
they go with it underwear yes yes and
little legs how would you know how would
you keep your balance after a while like
I that's like your biggest question that
how does the eat house a breed house it
here huh oh isn't listening right bye